Tại vì như thế này, nhìn mình có ai hoa, chứ?
Sao rồi, cho đồ rồi thì đo chạy nhằm mình về ai tìm
Anh tình thế này, sau khi thành toàn tất cả các khoảng nửa đánh,
kể các khoảng nửa đánh thà, thì mình còn chưa đến chục tìm
Anh tình một cái nhà khấn lắm sống tìt thôi, và sát tôi bằng tìm tìm lắm
Chỉnh vì thấy cho nên tôi mua các vội này, là vì bà ra
Đây là tôi đang thử nghiệp của tàn hộ mẫu thôi
Chưa riu của con này là nặng xây dịch một đều đạo giống tụi mình
Ờ, giúp khiến sẽ được bàn dạo nọng 2 không hay tán
Mà này
Hãy nhỏ cho đồ ngàn, đồ đạo xíng được một xúc mà tình mời
Víu xúc
Hãy đừng chồng
Hãy dạy mẹ thử với hòa ngàn có dồi
Nhưng mà cắt hộ nằm cho cố phía hợp
Nãy có mà tình chúng tâm thương mại
Một tình thái là nhà hàng, gặp về tình mà có trường mầm nó, về bơi
Gốc mà để giả trường phía bơi
Thường là nhà là để ở, dưới ở đây, mình được, vọng, cái như sống như riso
Ở chế muốn quán hộ không tạng như thế này
Một xúc giác lùu đẹp để mình sống thật
Và đồ ăn in để tật ở trời bà
Nếu mà cũng như tôi đã đi qua được ở nơi
Lát hảm thấy lùa, và chỉ còn một xấu cho người
Bà sẽ hiểu giá chỉ của 2 chữ, về in
Hởi của không lấy, tôi tìm thấy điều đó
Một nơi về lù siến để sống chậm, về lù đầy để một ngày chùa qua
Lều thấy giá đang nghĩ giữa trong chiến cắt nhà của mình